hey everybody welcome back to the park
attacks campaign mode and I just want to
start off this video really quickly by
thanking everybody for all of the
support that you've been giving to the
series it's been amazing it's been so
much better received than I expected
actually I was super afraid of the
series is becoming a bit of a niche
thing for just the small group of people
who were actually playing this game or
interested in this game but the support
has actually been really amazing not
just for the videos but lots of people
talking about the campaign which is
really cool to me as well having been
you know even if it's just a small part
of this game it's really cool to read
all of your comments also I when it's
right haha I've never tried that before
one of those little details where you
can click the plane and they all do like
tricks in any case yeah it's it's just
been amazing so thank you guys all so I
should probably notes if you're looking
at the map right now it's a little bit
different than it usually is because
it's a winter mode they apparently
decided to row out this sort of seasonal
updates so the maps should change
depending on the seasons but that said
the scenario Maps themselves should stay
more or less the same now about these in
the last episode I said at the end that
the next map would be Victoria Lake and
I guess I'm kind of wrong here because I
didn't realize that I would actually
branch off into different paths so we
can also do Western roundup
but that said I said I would do Victoria
Lake in the last video and it's also
scenario that I really want to start as
well since it's one of these scenarios
which I made it's actually one of the if
not the first scenario that I made
overall so this is really quite a
classic this one was made over a year
ago already and it's supposed to be one
of these sort of generic starting
scenarios but with a little bit of a
twist to the landscape so far the first
scenario of course completely empty and
the second one is still completely flat
so this is where you get some slight
terrain differences and well a bit more
of a challenge I suppose in what kind of
terraforming you have now I don't want
to talk too much about it before we go
into it but the scenario goal is to have
300 guests in the park which is a tiny
step up from
which makes sense and to not have any
loan debts so I'm gonna try my best to
also go around that now I suggest that
we go into it and I'll tell you a little
bit more as we are looking at the map
all right so I don't want to keep
referring back to roller coaster tycoon
at this point because it's a bit of a
moot point I think but this map was
definitely inspired my leafy lake in
roller coaster tycoon won I think some
people were suspecting this as well it's
very much based around the lake and you
kind of have to build around its in the
way that it's built as well I added this
castle later on because Sebastian asked
me to make some buildings in all of the
maps which could work as a trophy
as the building that gets put on the map
when you're done with the scenario and I
decided a castle over here would work
alright so that's a bit of a more recent
addition to the park but then the rest
of this is all pretty old now I split
the scenario design itself I already
said it's a bit inspired by leafy lake
in roller coaster tycoon I liked the
idea of having a sort of progression in
terms of terrain keeping the same sort
of difficulty of the first scenarios but
adding some more challenge in terms of
what kind of land area you gets and
having like a big body of water in the
middle of the park to work with but then
I thought the original scenario of leafy
lake is very tight very crammed there
isn't much space around Lake and then
there's this sort of awkward space at
the end of the park as well where you
suddenly get a whole lots of space but
it's kind of at a place where you might
not even have gotten to that point when
you're done with the scenario so I
thought it'd be a bit more fitting to at
least make the park layouts a little bit
wider around the lake keep the lake
quite small and make it more of a sort
of scenery aspects not to mention that a
theme parks around lakes are a very
common trope you've got parks like Hyde
Park and wannabe Belgium etc there's
lots of different examples I think it
works really well as something to build
a theme park to lay out on and in a
general sense you've got sort of three
like branching structures when it comes
to layouts of theme parks and then
you've got the sort of looping around
theme parks and I think a lake in the
side
works really well as the Lancer category
in any case I don't dwell too much also
I think it's about time that we start
heading into the actual building of
stuff I've tried to do some things in
the scenario earlier but because it's a
bit generic and there isn't so much to
follow a certain theme on I'm gonna try
and just follow a sort of generic
European ish thing on this one at the
very least make something that could
sort of fit into the look of the castle
over here so yeah let's start a
time-lapse and we'll see what I can come
up with all right now on some scenarios
I really sort of have my work cut out
for me and I think this is one of them
having that Main Street kind of looking
path leaning toward the lake and
splitting it off into two different
paths that move into different parts of
the park is a good starting point I
think for the Main Street and also a
water ride at the end of it with the
swan boats there so there's something
that sort of leads the guests to the
lake to check it out and maybe go on the
ride but there's also the parts where
the paths split up into different
directions and I think right in the
middle of that it's a good place to
build the information kiosk what I also
wanted to do though is actually turn
this into a real Main Street and I
didn't want to place buildings on both
sides of the Main Street I thought
that'd be a little bit too much and
probably also a little bit too expensive
I'm playing a scenario after all and
these things are getting slightly harder
every time so just one side of the Main
Street will be buildings and for this
style I was contemplating what I should
do with this for a while but I think in
the end sort of generic Renaissance ish
European theme should work more or less
I was thinking of medieval for a while
but I don't think that really fits the
generic Park entrance so I wanted to
have some kind of style weeks which
works with that and to be honest the the
castle at the edge of the map is also
not so much a real traditional medieval
castle but more of a sort of modern
interpretation of it I would say but
it's always kind of difficult a medieval
theme is really hard
to put because the medieval period is so
long and there are honestly so many
areas as well where you sort of have a
medieval theme it's very much a
Eurocentric theme I think and you can
really do a lot more with it but yeah I
wanted to avoid that whole mess so I'm
just going with a sort of overall 18
19th century sort of European look and I
do want to mix things up a little bit so
we have the corner building over there
which is the fanciest building of the
main street which a corner building very
often is because it's the most prominent
building you see it's quite a lot and
it's a really good opportunity to put a
little dome or spire or something fancy
on the corner as well so yeah that's
always nice but then for this building I
wanted to do something a little bit
different so we have the first floor
which is just regular old bricks and
then the sort of timber work second
floor there and a roof which is sort of
reminiscent of the Reds and tiled roofs
and honestly it's not even too strictly
any style it's sort of reminiscent I
suppose of Tudor buildings in England
but there's also plenty of buildings
that look like this in Belgium and in
France and Germany so you know having a
generic European theme is kind of risky
because there's really no such thing as
generic European but with enough of a
mixture and buildings that could look
like they're from multiple places I
think it should more or less work
because I didn't want to focus on a
single country I think this could be
anywhere between the France and Germany
anywhere in that sort of area so yeah
there's that and the final building or
really the the first building if you're
coming from the entrance of the park is
just going to sell umbrellas I believe I
don't know if it's going to be too
useful but I already made a food courts
out of the corner building so at least
it has some kind of function and it's
going to be pretty simple in terms of
what it looks like but just to be able
to sort of fit the look in with the
console a little bit more I decided to
draw the general color scheme from the
castle and this is something that I've
probably talked about quite a few times
in many of my different videos but as a
general tip when it
- picking colors for buildings one
strategy that almost always works is to
pick three colors for a building one
color for the roof one for the walls and
one for the details or accents and
mostly that works you have some
exceptions like the brick building with
the rent roof having sort of different
styles for different floors and this
building being much more generic really
having a color scheme of two colors in
general but it's something to keep in
mind having four or five different
completely different colors for a single
building almost never really works out
if even if you're going for a super
colorful theme just picking a certain
set of three colors per building maybe
even two colors per building should
always work out fine so on the coronary
building for instance there's a sort of
beige color of all of the walls and
things that are attached to the walls
and then there's the dark greyish color
for the roof and some of the details
there and there's a bit of red accents
in the awnings so a general strategy
like that could work quite well I think
you could also have the awnings be the
same color as the roof color for
instance and go with completely
different colors for the pillars there's
a bunch of ways in which you can have a
sort of variation in that but picking a
sort of three color color scheme for a
building before moving into it I think
it's always a pretty easy and sound
strategy to make sure that your colors
are on point anyway I got a hurry up
because I'm already building a coaster
over here and somebody corrected me last
episode on what kind of coaster this is
so I should probably talk about that a
little bit I call this the the bakoma
junior coaster or Volos skater in the
last episode but it's not really that
because this has diagonal cross ties
which the vakama roller skater doesn't
so I should correct myself there and
while they're in the comments the person
said that it's probably a 0t Valley
coaster which i think is correct when it
comes to the trains because they have
these articulated sort of junior coaster
trains but then the actual track has
tubular rails so I think it's it's a bit
of a mixture of difference real life
family coasters it's probably the the
trains of a zero Tivoli coaster
and then the rails of a zero ESC coaster
I believe but in any case it's
definitely not of a coma roller skater
so for the layouts I thought it'd be
interesting to have three helixes each
one in a different direction which is
the holy grill if Emily coasters and
then his second parts where it sort of
moves over the lake and has some
interaction with the paths as well as
the water right down there and overall I
am actually really happy with this
layout it came oh it's a lot better than
I expected
it's very loosely based on the coaster
that I built in the same place when I
was sort of testing this scenario when I
was still working on it
but it's it's actually a lot better than
the earlier version so that's good and
it also makes pretty good use I think if
the new option of the coaster creator to
transition into different curves in
different well
banks I suppose and also the option that
you have at the end to connect your
track to the very first rank because
that used to be a big problem we're
connecting back to the station if you're
honest slightly different heights used
to be really difficult
in pike tech but now the the game just
sort of does that automatically so that
was super useful as well because I
wouldn't be able to build this layout as
nicely without that and as for the
scenery it's all just pretty simple I
don't want to seem anything too much yet
here it's kind of a similar case to
maple Meadows it's a bit of a small
family ish Park even though it might
have some scenery we have a bit of a
Main Street going here it's not quite on
Disney levels so I think a generic sort
of mostly unnamed except for the queue
and station approach to the coaster I
think works out more or less in this
gate in this case and then there's the
little square I wanted to put that roof
over there just to make this area feel a
little bit more like a square I did like
the idea of having it as a sort of look
out over the lake but I wanted to have
something to sort of end the Main Street
in some kind of mass which sort of
signifies and and turns this area with
the information kiosk into its small
square
so I think that mostly works for that
and over here I had some space left and
I decided to just build a small pavilion
to preserve the idea of a main street
here and maybe have a nice place for
people to I don't know stand and watch
the coaster go around something like
that and over here I decided to put an
area where people can sit and eat
because there's the food court nearby
but there's not really a place inside
the food court to eat it's really just
stalls it's really small so this is
going to be the area where if people are
getting a lot of food and want to sit
somewhere they should probably do it in
here it's also a nice place to get some
benches and put some parasols everywhere
which always looks quite fancy so I
really like that and I also almost
forgot to build a toilet so here it goes
here's the toilet so people can actually
go there as well I always forgot to
place these things when I was playing
planet coaster but in this case we
really need these things from a gameplay
perspective so I'm not forgetting about
these things anytime soon I do want to
keep hiding them in small buildings
though and this building also doubles as
a way to hide the depot which is behind
it so that the scenery rating doesn't
tank too much because the paths over
here are pretty close to the depot and
finally and you might have seen the
colors of the seating area change a
little bit here my computer actually
blue screen for a second there so I had
to rebuilt that and I took the
opportunity to slightly mess a little
bit with the colors make them a bit
darker and more vibrant but in any case
I decided to build a carousel over here
not really because I thought I'd be the
best flat ride but if you look at my
money over there there's not much of it
left so that was just about all that I
could do and also teammates to a decent
extent so yeah that's basically it
and at this point I need to get back
into the game and see if I can somehow
financially save this park because it's
in a bit of a rut right now alright I
hope I wasn't going too fast there
because I had a lot to talk about doing
that time lapse but here's the park and
we're doing pretty shabby
we're losing $137 per
at the moment that's not very good but I
hope sincerely that I can make some
money out of the coaster which I have
right now because I know for sure that
the water ride and the carousel and the
slide aren't going to make too much
money although as for the carousel for
some reason it seems to be pretty
popular so far is the price on this good
I could probably ask much more for that
I'm gonna ask these people $3 for a
carousel which is absolutely ridiculous
but we'll see if they want to pay and Oh
what are you thinking a bit more intense
all right I've had enough of this Pike
Oh God
alright well I'm sorry about that's I
haven't seen any Vandals yet so I'm a
bit afraid that I won't be able to show
that any time soon but it's vandals in
the impact act they're really funny
because they get like this bandana or
something they they start looking like
vandals basically and then they break
stuff and then they get out of your park
and it's always fun to spot them and
drop them into a lake or something in
any case I hope we're doing fine the
coaster is running an empty train that's
not very good
ah because it's broken alright um I
think I'm gonna have to run the park for
a little bit longer to see if we're
actually doing fine when it comes to
money so I'll see if I can somehow turn
this around and run a profit and
otherwise I am gonna go for the very
sustainable but probably not so much
strategy or just getting big loans in
building more lines and hopefully we'll
be able to solve our money issues that
way but yeah it's not that the scenario
isn't easy this is definitely a really
easy scenario I just went way too much
into the scenery parts of things and
turns out that this whole Main Street
and all of the scenery around it was
pretty expensive so I'll see if we can
somehow turn that around
aha and there you go now we're making
profits so that's pretty good that's
actually happening much sooner than I
expected so I won't be failing this
scenario at the very least now in the
last episode I also got some questions
whether I wanted to do some POVs of the
coast rooms because this was actually
very much
wasted people really liked to have
unwrite videos but I have to say it's
not a part of pike thanks vanilla there
is a mod which allows you to go on right
when it comes to your coasters but
personally I like to keep the game in
isometric mode since I think that's
where the appeal of it is that's where
there's sort of a nostalgic look to the
game comes from but also I think that's
what helps the game be very management
focused and allows you to stay focused
on management even if you're looking
into design and creativity as well
because as soon as you go completely 3d
it very much becomes a sort of immersive
experience
and I think by keeping it isometric you
still get that sort of aerial
perspective which changes things a
little bit I think it keeps you out of
the park itself and keeps you as a sort
of benevolence or maybe malevolence
creator so I'm gonna stay in this sort
of perspective but what you can do is
aim the camera at the car and I'm gonna
actually have to fix some of the timing
on these block brakes because they
always have to wait on top of the left
of the lift Hill which is a little bit
annoying but yeah you can basically have
the camera follow the e train but that's
about all that you can do so it's not
too special but you can watch it go
around which is pretty nice I should
also say I had some requests to turn
some of my coaster layouts and maybe
even my buildings into blueprints and
I'll definitely think about that I'm not
sure if I'll be linking them down in the
description for all of the videos but
for some of the stuff which i think is
blueprint worthy I'll try to upload it
and this coaster for instance I think
it's good enough to turn into a
blueprint so yeah if you check my Steam
Workshop I basically have the exact same
name on Steam as my youtube name
you can hopefully find some of the stuff
from my scenarios in there so there's
that and that was the coaster and I
think overall it's pretty good it's not
really a good time to check the graphs
but it's a good time to check
test results and I think overall the
excitement is pretty good but the
intensity is still very low so in the
end I'm gonna need some more intense
rides I think because I really don't
have anything intense yet speaking of
which I don't think I need to research
anything I just need to earn more money
to be able to afford especially this one
because this is gonna be really intense
so that's a bit of a goal I think I can
do fine with you wooden coaster for now
I don't think I have to really research
many more coasters or anything like this
all that I really need to think about is
where I want to place that thing and I
am considering placing it along the lake
here and making it into sort of a
skyline type attraction but yeah I'll
have to think about that a little bit
more sort of comes back to the park
layout that I talked about earlier I
feel like if I put a wooden coaster over
there I almost kind of feels like
Canobie Lake Park which has balderdash
in it as well as I believe a few other
Woody's which aren't as good but anyway
a sort of classic sort of traditional
feeling theme park with a lot of wooden
coasters and other classic theme park
rides I think that's a general good
theme for this scenario so that's
something I'll go for and alright I
think that's that's pretty much it it's
good time to probably still get some
loans because I don't want to wait until
I earn more money so I'm just gonna get
a loan and expand into probably this
part of the park I should also say I put
some signs over here there's one over
here as well and one over here to make
sure that the guests don't walk around
the entire lake and I highly suggest you
do the same when you get these scenarios
with a lot of pots or Bank areas of the
park because scenarios will be because
guests will go to these points of the
scenarios and they won't be able to do
anything there and they'll just be
getting disappointed and sad and not
spending any money on your rights so
yeah always try to put some signs on the
dead and areas of your park when you're
not yet building anything there
now with that said let's get into
another time lapse and build some more
flat rights all right now my plan to
build more flat rides didn't end up
working very well and I'll give you a
bit of a spoiler I almost went into
bankruptcy and I had to go back to an
older safe to fix the park so here's the
issue I don't have anything to make some
of my thrill one demanding guests happy
I suppose so
in a lot of cases if your park doesn't
make the guests happy or it doesn't make
a certain subset of the guests happy
they'll turn into vandals and they'll
start destroying everything and this
problem can go bad really quickly and I
think this plater is a good example of
it so you can see right now I'm trying
to use the mechanics and janitors to
clean up everything all the time but
honestly the Vandals destroy stuff
quicker then I can clean it up and a lot
of this process costs money as well and
like even if a mechanic repairs a bench
it takes some of your money so we get
these vandals these guys with the
bananas over here and now get back into
that doing the real time section as well
but basically I couldn't really stop
them and I had an imminent bankruptcy
there so I decided to go back and get a
really big loan and try to prevent all
of this from happening by building more
thrill rides so I put the same thrill
ride near the water there but clearly
that thing wasn't enough so I'm adding
this pirate ship as well I'm not doing
too much scenery quite yet I really just
want to try and put some quick rides
with easy money in just to fix the park
and hopefully make people less angry and
try to actually run a profit as well
because as you can see the minimal
profit that I was running was quickly
destroyed by the fact that people were
unhappy and turning into vandals all
over the place so a few thrill rides and
a rollercoaster to fix that issue is
basically when I was thinking of that
said I didn't want to plop them down in
a sense to remove them later or just you
know as a gameplay focus so I also
wanted to have them well at least looks
somewhat nice and be able to maybe pick
it up later during the play
and improve the general look at the flat
rides so I do want to keep these things
around and I do want to theme them a
little bit later this is just a very
basic sort of way to fix the issue that
we have right now and I think some of
these rides which all have at least a
medium intensity rating should fix the
issue more or less but it's quite
difficult especially since you don't
start off with a lot of very thrilling
rides right at the start now over here
this wooden coaster I built this thing
purely to try and fix the park a little
bit more try and get something a bit
more intense and something that attracts
more guests so this thing is gonna be
temporary I was playing I was planning
to put a wooden coaster here in the end
but it's this super simple sort of oh
its impact layouts
is something that I decided to just keep
in the park for as long as I needed but
as soon as I make enough money and the
guests are happy I want to change it
anyway now the first iteration of this
wasn't quite intense enough so I decided
to make a slightly different version
from it with some airtime Hills that are
way too tight but should hopefully make
some good airtime to give us a good
intensity rating same goes for the
positive G's of the bottom and I removed
the brakes for the curve so that we can
have some extra lateral G's in that
curve as well and yeah get a generally
medium intensity when in coaster for not
that much money and then over here is a
little bit of scenery when it comes to
the flat ride over here but during the
process of that something happened ok so
that's a little bit awkward I really
just wanted to save the park and get my
finances in order and I wasn't anywhere
near finishing what I wanted to finish
but now I already reached the goal of
the scenario it seems so that's one goal
that we've reached though that's 300
guests in the park but then the other
goal is to have no loan debts so I'm
still fine and oh god those vandals are
still doing their thing but um maybe
it's a good idea anyway to take a small
realtime section to show everything
let's
more so I've been continuously checking
for the decoration and vandalism tabs
what's going on in the park
I had enormous problems with vandals
before I had any of the more intense
rides but now it seems that most of
those problems have been fixed so I have
a little bit of vandalism like this
stuff over here but it's not anywhere
near as bad as it used to be so really
having no thrill rides in your park and
operating on just gentle rides
absolutely kills your Park and that was
definitely the biggest issue that I had
before
now the temporary wooden coaster is
something that I would still like to
turn into a real thing so I think it
might be a good idea to just wait with
repaying the loan until I have the kind
of park then I want to have and then
once everything is up and running and it
looks good I can finish the repayment of
the loan and that'll be the end of the
scenario so in a way having that sort of
extra well extra level of difficulty by
having to repay the loan
it kind of makes sense it works out in
this case so I'm pretty happy with that
I'm not entirely sure how this works
right so I can basically repay a
thousand of my loan right now okay I see
how that takes away a thousand so it's
not gonna automatically repay the loan
so I think it's good to drop that
thousand but for now I think I'm gonna
try and keep this park running and just
keep a bit of loan in there until I'm
done with the park as I want it to be
then keep the finances in order and we
should be able to make it alright so
let's get back into the timelines but
before I do that actually I'd like to
look an offender over here so here's one
guy with a banana actually that's it's
like a mask for your mouth I don't know
exactly what to call those things anyway
so here's is a guy that is pretty much
looking like a vandal over here and then
he's taking some well-needed rest I
suppose after destroying half my Park
yeah let's just repair
the stuff that he's broken I think this
guy alone is gonna destroy a lot of the
park if I just let him keep going yeah
there he goes just destroys the lamp
that I just prepared so normally what
you do with these guys I mean you can
drop them into a lake if you so desire
but you can just ban them out of the
park then I'll get mad and then they'll
leave and I've checked this on a couple
of guys but it seems that on their way
to the to the entrance
they don't really destroy anything else
so banning them pretty much saves you
all of the problems that these guys
normally cause but yeah they are quite a
problem so vandalism was really the the
major issue and still is I mean if you
keep going around here there are some
broken lamps and some broken trash cans
and I'm not seeing any other vandals at
the moment but it's definitely a big
issue in the park so that's something
that I hope got fixed by the extra
thrill rides but we'll have to see I
also hired a security guy and an extra
mechanic and hopefully that should solve
the issue at least partly as well but as
you can see they are still going around
breaking stuff in Wow god that's
terrible
hold up let me replace some of that I
don't see anybody walking around causing
anything but just one or two vandals out
there there is a guy there he is let's
bend that guy already so yeah I don't
know what he's thinking oh he's also
banned ah that's pretty good
I don't remember bending that guy but
sure all right sometimes you get these
ridiculous vandals like I just had as
well who complains about the vandalism
in the park which is a bit strange as
well it's a bit of an [ __ ] move but
sure whatever they're into but yeah this
is definitely one of the biggest
challenges that I've had in a game so
far and I don't know if it's just
because of the lack of thrill rides or
if there's other factors like a lack of
toilets or anything like that in there
as well oh there it is
it is a banana okay fair enough alright
but yeah it doesn't seem like there's
anything particularly causing it
his happiness is actually quite high for
somebody who's destroying everything
although I guess maybe panther use a
girl name I don't know in any case it's
getting out of the pike right now so
that's one van one less but it's it's
still a big problem like I can go here
and there's another destroyed lamp and
here's another destroyed lamp but in
another destroyed bench and another
vandal so I'll spend some time thinking
about this then I'll get back to
building anyway let's go back into the
time lives alright so for this
time-lapse I can take things a little
bit more slowly because I'm really just
finishing up the park to whatever points
that I feel it's done and I want to move
on to the next scenario and I went into
the idea of how to fix vandalism for a
little bit and I found a reddit thread
where people also found a very similar
sort of not really an issue but
challenged I suppose because it's part
of the game I basically had this wave of
vandals come over into my park and
there's not much you can do about that
apparently apparently they just come
into the park looking for a riot and
looking to destroy things and at that
point your only real defense against it
is either drowning them yourself or just
having enough security to take care of
that in some way and I should also say
when I saw the Vandal earlier which was
already banned apparently that's what
security does which I didn't even notice
I thought it would be just that wherever
security is vandals don't do their
vandalizing activities but if they're
caused by security they get banned from
the park and leave that's pretty
interesting actually so apparently if
you have a wave of these vandals the
best advice is to just have enough
security and have them walk around as
much as possible to try and minimize the
damage but you can always also go for
the strategy of just having a lot of
people just repair and maintain all of
the paths and you know even though stuff
gets broken you always have the guys
repair it as well
so that's that now on this side of the
park I decided to not completely finish
the loop around the lake because I want
to save some space for the wooden
coaster and I think to completely build
an entire park around the entire lake
would be a little bit too much maybe I
think it'd be fair to stop just at this
ferris wheel and worth finishing the
wooden coaster and just leave it at that
obviously I could build a lot more into
the park and it would feel much more
finished but at some points I do want to
finish the scenario and move to the next
thing
I think there's maybe some things you
can pick up on this when I upload it
into the workshop and maybe finish it
yourself
I also have to keep in mind that while
these scenarios might be quite easy and
I can focus on scenery quite a lot even
though I do get these gameplay
challenges every now and then like the
van door problem it's gonna be a little
bit harder for some of the later parks
in the campaign mode to actually theme
them to this extent so I don't want to
go all outs over here yet because I'm
gonna have to face a bit more
challenging parks later on so I do want
to have a comparatively similar level of
theming when it comes to that so yeah
that's that I just wanted to finish this
area with a few extra flat rights one
toilet building over here actually
that's not a toilet building that's the
one that I just built this is the
vending machine building because I
didn't want to build a whole Depot and
do all of that infrastructure but for
people who did want a snack or a drink
or something I think a vending machine
should more or less work and then
there's the ferris wheel over there and
the drop tower which is not too big you
can always raise it a little bit but I
thought a slightly smaller drop tower
like that should work fine in any case I
also like these things a lot in real
life there are some of my favorite drop
towers but I shouldn't dwell on that too
much because I'm actually gonna built
the wooden coaster over here and this
was quite a bit of an experiment I
suppose for the first time in this game
I tried building a GCI wooden coaster
and for those of you who don't know GCI
or
great coasters international is a wooden
coaster manufacturer with a very
distinct type of track layouts and feel
to the coasters and they also have these
typical trains you see the articulated
trains right there with two people per
car and then there's just a very long
row of cars per train that's how these
things typically look and they're known
for that but they're also known for
their snappy transitions and how smooth
yet still very not entirely rough but
but they're coasters kind of shake you
around in a good way and it's that sort
of layouts which I try to recreate in
parks tact here and it's something that
I never really dared to do so far but
the new feature that allows you to
connect two ends of the track when there
are no pieces in the piece by piece
track creator that can actually connect
the two parts just makes so many more
possibilities in terms of what kind of
transitions you build between curves so
for an example over here I decided to
build that little hill over there and
remove it and turn what used to be two
pieces into one piece by having the auto
connects connect the two pieces and by
doing this you can have a single piece
that goes from banks to unbanked while
going up and down at the same time and
some other stuff like that you can
basically create much smoother but also
different transitions than before so
even though I think this was added into
the game just to make connecting to the
station a little bit easier it really
opens up a lot of possibilities when it
comes to making coasters in the game in
general you can create all these
different transitions as long as you are
on a piece where there's a straight
piece of track and the difference in
Heights between the two pieces that
you're trying to connect isn't too much
but even then it's something which makes
making coasters like GCI wooden coasters
a lot easier so yeah another thing I
should probably note about this these
coasters tend to have these typical
drops where it curves down doing the
drop so that's why the first drop is
like that
and they also have a lot of interesting
sort of ways in which the hills are
shaped and I've been explained this by
somebody who works in the company which
is been created by some of the former
bosses of GCI it's bit too complicated
for me to explain in one video if you're
watching this Dustin
thanks but basically they're their
layouts are calculated in a very unique
way which results in these these layouts
with curves that have their little hills
and stuff inside the curves so over here
you can see I'm moving into a curve and
then I'm keeping the bank and going from
straights to a slope down and then
curving again which is something that
normally you don't really see you'd
normally just kind of smoothly follow
the curves but these coasters often have
these very sudden transitions where it
just goes straight for a little bits or
something like that and I think it's
this what makes them so interesting it
gives you these tiny little pops of
airtime throughout the ride which is
really cool and I might not be the best
at making a layout of this kind of
coaster or help architect might not even
be the best game to try this sort of
thing in but I decided to just do it in
this case and if you didn't exactly
understand me I can totally understand
that's because my explanation wasn't all
so good just take it as in these
coasters are really unique and I tried
my best to sort of emulates their kind
of layouts in parca texts because we
have this this new way of making layouts
now the station is actually another
typical GCI feature I think a lot of
these wooden coasters you can recognize
them by the fact that they have a part
of the track which flies through the
station which is really interesting it
usually goes above the station so when
you're standing there and you're waiting
for the train that you can board you'll
always have another train just kind of
crash through the station it's the most
loud thing ever and it's a bit annoying
maybe sometimes but it's really cool at
the same time so I wanted to feature
that as well so we have the coaster
track
one floor above the station going
through the station building and then
the station building itself is pretty
compact as well there are some stairs
and stuff for the entrance and the exit
in the middle of it so it was a bit of a
puzzle to figure out how to actually put
all of this stuff underneath one roof
but I think in the end it more or less
works out it's not too complicated it
looks a lot more complicated than it is
but it works out is a pretty GCI ish
station I think so there's that I also
decided to put some extra supports under
some parts of the track because some
supports disappeared and realistically
in wooden coasters you then get some
some metal beams that sort of connect
the different parts of the wooden
coaster that are under supported and a
very simple cue with a little roof over
there and finally I'm adding some of the
foliage to make sure that it all just
blends into the park quite nicely so
that's more or less its aside from this
I'm not really adding anything
substantial into the park so you can see
that there is a big empty space between
this wooden coaster and where the ferris
wheel is which isn't really connected in
any way but I just want to keep it this
way
and I think after all in the end the
park turned out quite nice I'm pretty
happy with how it turned out and I'm
actually really happy with the GCI
coaster it's not the perfect layouts but
I think there is definitely potential in
making these kinds of wooden coasters
and park things in any case let's move
into a quick real time section for a
final overview okay so here's our wooden
coaster happily doing its rounds I do
have to add I change the ending bits a
little bit because as I said they have
these interesting transitions of going
up and down during the curves which
makes it feel as if you have these
straight sections during the curves but
if you look from above they're actually
completely curved so my reference for
this coaster was mostly Troy in
toverland
and this is something I noticed looking
at that coaster and the final helix that
I had before was looking super square
because of the different transitions so
I think this one even though it's a
little bit less of what I was trying to
go for
works out a little bit more so yeah
that's also why the coaster is in test
mode despite the fact that I can pretty
much open it at this point and for an
example of these new transitions going
from straights to a banked sort of
position while also going up and down if
we look over here this entire track
piece is one piece so you can see that
the track and it will pass by here in a
second so you can see that it is pretty
smooth it starts going up over here and
starts slightly banking and during that
it also starts to go straight again at
the end of the piece to smoothly
transition into that curve and before
this I would have made I would have had
to turn this into two different pieces
so one piece where it goes up and then
one piece where it starts banking and
goes to straight or something like that
it would have been a lot less smooth and
a lot less nice to look at I think
especially the transition over here at
the end is super nice where it kind of
curves down and at the same time it goes
to like the banking goes straight so
it's super cool so I actually really
like this addition to the coaster
builder overall I'm pretty happy with
the layouts and it's not too much to see
again I can't really do an on-ride of it
but I am quite happy with it saying
let's just open it and as for the park
itself I'm also quite glad with how this
came out definitely really prefer the
entrance area out of any other point of
the park but then again I think that
makes sense it's definitely the most
important part of the park I should also
address and I've had some comments about
this on my previous videos you can see
some lag in my videos and I have to say
in part this is fraps because even
though it's a rather it's OBS because I
still haven't figured out its how to
perfectly get it to smoothly run while
also running the game at the same time I
think my CPU is not too happy with it
but partly it's definitely also the game
itself since these parks do end up
getting a lot of scenery and a lot more
scenery pieces I think that most people
will use on their playthroughs so that's
definitely a factor as well but overall
I've noticed that there is more lag in
the videos than I'm really seeing myself
like there is not too much bothering me
right now so that's something I have to
look into but if you're watching the
first video of maple Meadows for
instance and wondering about the leg at
the end it should be fine you can get
the game so yeah there's that and then
there's this little area over here which
even though it's small actually quite
like as well it still has a pretty
charming feel to it I think it's also
interesting how they sort of
unintentionally turned into the thrill
rides corner of the park where some of
the more intense rides are over here
there's really just a Gravitron but most
of the things on this side is kind of
you know that the family-oriented rides
so yeah that's pretty much it for this
park I don't think I can nicely fit the
whole thing in one view maybe something
like this that's just about good enough
I think so right now I think it's time
to pay off my loan because even though I
wasn't for quite a while after I
finished the coaster I can now pretty
much repay the whole thing and then if
my memory serves me rights I should be
able to finish the scenario right away
that's not the message of how I was
waiting for hold on so I've completed
all goals nice so there we go there's
the confetti I wasn't able to show you
guys earlier but this is what happens
when you finish a scenario so let's save
that under the second Victoria Lake the
one that didn't completely crash and
burn and let's take a look at the main
map because something that I didn't know
before either but I have to read into is
the fact that you apparently get coins
for completing the goals of scenarios
and you get extra coins for completing
the optional goals and you need these
coins to unlock new scenarios so it's
not a super linear thing not only do you
get like multiple branches of scenario
paths that you can go down but you also
get more scenarios depending on how many
of the of the optional goals you
complete although I should also note you
don't need to complete any of the
optional goals you will be able to play
every scenario if you
don't complete any of the optional goals
so there's that but in my case I'm
actually kind of curious how well I did
on this scenario I don't think I got all
of the yeah there you go
mostly the final challenge goal is
completing by the end of September year
to do well I'm in year six which is
pretty pretty bad I guess anyway let's
stick the main menu and see what we've
got
all right we finished Victoria Lake
there it is the trophy the castle that I
built earlier it's super cool to see it
in here like this
oh and that fits really nicely in the
map as well so the next scenario is
gonna be oh yeah it's gonna be coral
Calgary caldera there we go but I still
need more coins for that apparently so
the next one is actually going to be
Western roundup that's interesting this
is one that I didn't make myself this is
one that Joshua made and then this is a
scenario which I made but I can't really
get to which is also why I know the name
of the scenario sometimes it can be a
little bit confusing because you have
these names for sort of the areas on the
map but these are just sort of you know
Park Plains being this general area of
the map so these aren't actually the
scenario names so the scenario in here
is coral caldera but we'll get to that
some other day the next episode we'll
look at Western roundup
so yeah thanks for watching guys and
I'll see you all next time